[Musique]
c'est une question qui inquiète la
communauté scientifique faut-il
permettre les robots tueurs ces machines
intelligentes capables de tuer qui
pourrait remplacer les soldats sur les
champs de bataille
alors que plus de 70 pays sont réunis à
genève pour faire le point des voix
s'élèvent contre ces robots tueurs et
compris celle du milliardaire et le losc
le fondateur de tesla
alors pour mieux comprendre les enjeux
je reçois yoshua bengio il est directeur
scientifique de l'institut
d'intelligence artificielle du québec
alors on sort monsieur bendjo merci
d'être avec nous alors vous faites
partie de ces gens qui mettent en garde
la communauté internationale de ses
robots tueurs alors qu'est ce qu'un
robot tueur et quels sont les dangers
tout simplement c'est des armes qui
peuvent tuer sans l'intervention d'un
humain donc si on accepte ce genre dame
ça veut dire qu'on délègue la décision
de tuer parfois il ya des circonstances
qui font que ça prend vraiment jugement
moral pour pour savoir quelle est la
bonne chose à faire et si on regarde la
législation internationale
c'est très encadré alors il faut pas
qu'on permette contre qu'on permette
soit il faut pas qu'on n'est pas cette
ligne morale et c'est pour ça que des
centaines de scientifiques au canada
demande à nos gouvernements d'intervenir
et de soutenir notre l'effort
international qui existe déjà depuis
plusieurs années pour qu'on ait un
traité international contre des robots
tueurs avait d'ailleurs envoyé une
lettre au premier ministre trudeau il ya
quelques jours exactement
puis c'est vraiment les chercheurs la
communauté des chercheurs en est
essentiel pour eux c'est vraiment
important qu'on prenne cette question au
sérieux pour que l'international soit
développée au service de tous au
bénéfice de l'humanité et non pas à
encourager une mauvaise utilisation de
ces technologies
alors quels sont les dangers de ces
robots tueurs bien les dangers ce qui
permettrait de tuer de manière très
ciblée des populations des
sous-populations on peut imaginer que un
gouvernement décida on va tuer tous les
gens qui sont par exemple des musulmans
ou qui sont des chercheurs en
intelligence artificielle dans tel pays
à partir simplement de la photo d'une
personne
il ya déjà des systèmes qui peuvent
reconnaître cette personne là et donc si
on combine cette capacité de reconnaître
les personnes avec la capacité de tuer
avec des drones
on a des robots tueurs c'est pas quelque
chose qui va arriver dans dix ans c'est
quelque chose qui peut se faire assez
rapidement
alors une fois qu'on a accès justement
ces robots tueurs et on a un peu ouvert
la boîte de pandore est ce que ce n'est
pas plus difficile de la refermer
oui je pense qu'il faut agir le plus tôt
possible
on voit jamais être capable de
complètement empêcher des états de
tricher même s'il y avait un très peiné
par contre l'effet d'avoir un traité
international ça pourrait avoir un effet
très important pour réduire l'impact de
ces en produire la quantité de sézanne
en circulation pour en faire quelque
chose qui soit immorales au niveau
international ça a fonctionné avec les
mines antipersonnel même si des pays
comme les etats unis qui n'ont pas signé
le traité
grâce au traité après quelques années on
voit que les états unis et les
compagnies américaines ont cessé de
participer à la fabrication de ces
enveloppes la même chose pourrait
arriver avec les robots tueurs alors là
on voit que la communauté scientifique
est divisé sur cette question là ce que
c'est réaliste de penser que les nations
unies pourraient faire signer un traité
sont tout à fait en fait elle n'est pas
divisée chez les chercheurs qui sont des
experts dans le domaine
c'est clair que c'est quelque chose
qu'on veut éviter alors évidemment il y
à des personnes plutôt du côté des
organisations militaires qui craignent
qu'on leur mette un peu des bâtons dans
les roues qu'on s'est un peu un dialogue
qui nécessaire là pour faire en sorte
qu' on ne vise pas la sécurité au
contraire qu'on améliore avec
décision collective au niveau de la
planète pour éviter ce genre de système
là pour terminer monsieur bendjo d'un
point de vue éthique évidemment vous
c'est que votre plus grande crainte
c'est laquelle la plus grande crainte
générale puis ça inclut le cas des
robots tueurs c'est que ces technologies
vont devenir assez puissante puis
comment est-ce qu'elles vont utiliser
est ce que on voit les usi seulement
pour le bien où est ce qu'on va
s'organiser collectivement politiquement
socialement pour éviter les abus de ses
technologies
les bénéfices des robots tueurs c'est
des bénéfices pour par exemple des
gouvernements autoritaires qui veulent
contrôler leur population ou carrément
agresser des populations de notre pays
en pouvant tuer sélectivement des
personnes dans sept autres pays de
manière à une vitesse et d'une manière
qui qui qui nous dépasse et donc quand
est ce qu'on sait tant réponse peut-être
une résolution des nations unies qui
malheureusement les nations unies ça
bouge pas vite donc cette semaine
depuis aujourd'hui il ya des rencontres
à l'onu toutes les semaines des
discussions qui vont porter sur cette
question c'est pour ça qu'on voulait que
le gouvernement du canada s'impliquent
et avec d'autres pays qui pousse un peu
cette idée d'un traité international
fasse en sorte qu'on ait graduellement
sa va pas se faire du jour au lendemain
faire un traité international contre les
robots tueurs
merci beaucoup avec plaisir